[BLANK_AUDIO]
My kiss, I got it.
All right, last time you guys successfully got the keys from Harvard.
And you're on your way to the bank.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So you were told by, what the fuck is the name?
Bramble to get a small chest from the World Government banks,
and directors came in.
You went to the casino, you gambled your money, you got a good winning.
About what was it, nine million or something.
And you also got the keys.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So now, it's almost night.
You've been there for about four hours.
And maybe it's like nine or 10 p.m.
The bank is probably closed.
But you see still guards are about the bank, right?
So how do you want to handle this?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Can we hide out somewhere and kind of see if there's a pattern to the guards
where we can slip in while they're not looking?
We're in disguises.
They don't know where it just has.
You are in disguises, but if you come in view of the bank,
they will kind of notice you and ask you what you're here.
That's why I said hide.
Yeah, okay.
So you want to hide behind these, let's say the crates lying around here.
Do you all want to hide?
No, fuck that, we haven't done anything wrong, I'm just don't walk past.
Pretend like nothing's going on.
I'm a stumble around like I'm drunk.
All right, so you want to distract the guards.
I'm just walking past.
Walking past to where?
You have to go in the bank.
Like, but just like walk, at least say that little fountain that's in front of them.
I'm going to stumble around and go to the fountain and you like.
You can go around.
And go to the fountain without any problems.
I think if you're staying clear of the bank, what about you guys?
What are you going to do?
I'll hide with red.
Inside over here my boxes.
I'm just going to stop you both of you roll for stealth with advantage because they still don't see you.
You can hide.
Natural.
Let's go.
So you can hide behind those.
Barrels and whatnot lying around.
I am a girl now.
Waiting for your next steps.
I'll say sap.
Play a bone path to stealth.
What do you want them to do?
Baptiste, you will also be stealthed.
But I'd say you have to make another stealth check when you get close.
I have a question.
Because you said like they have guns.
Like is it like a laser beam?
Like is it quiet?
They do have guns.
And it is kind of like a laser beam.
They don't make too much noise.
So since I'm on this side, can I see if there's anybody around?
I mean, you can see whatever you can see.
That's all you see.
Because I only see the two guards.
I don't know what you know.
Well, then shit.
I'm going to be a distraction.
I'm going to jump in the fucking fountain here and try to drink it.
And pretend like I'm drunk.
It starts singing in the rain.
See if I can't draw these two guards to come step forward.
One of the guards signals the other guards to stay still while he goes and takes care of you.
The guard steps up and he's like, sir, you can't do that to the fountain.
Please get out of the fountain and leave right away.
Why do I got a leaf?
I'm singing in the rain.
This is private property.
You can do whatever you're doing in the fountain.
You want to see what is the fountain somewhere?
Either property.
Or the property of the bank.
How close is he?
He's here.
If you're in the fountain, then he's just outside, right outside of the place where you're here.
Yeah.
What you guys doing?
I'm just going to sit down and then wait.
Okay, so while he's in the fountain.
Visible is less than hour.
Someone go invisible and try to sneak past the other guard.
Go invisible.
You have the keys.
But you will still have to make a stealth role to unlock the door.
If I see her going invisible, can I just drop out from hiding so she can walk out and just start walking around the direction to jam the guard that's in towards the need?
Yeah, so he's going to draw the other guard away.
Okay, what do you want to do to distract the other guy?
So I'm just going to walk close.
And then it looks like I'm trying to go behind the other guard.
So I'm just walking past.
The guard will probably see that and he'll try to stop you.
That's what we want.
Sir, please get away from the bank.
You are not allowed to be around here.
I'm going to hold out my money.
I'm going to hold out my finger to the other guard in front of me.
Like I'm just like, just amount, just amount, just amount.
Do you want Sappoli to do anything here?
I think they're supposed to be, are they supposed to be like a, like posing as like a marine that would come and help if everything came up?
So, haven't just stand off yet.
So I don't think they're particularly stealthy anyway.
I was soon being a giant.
I wrote it.
Now, my question is, do we have Sappoli like tell these other guards like, hey, can you guys get these guys off the premises?
The boss is supposed to be coming down here.
Like, Sappoli will go over and tell them the boss is coming for something.
He has to check on something. So can you guys, can you guys get rid of them?
And the guards will ask for their posts and everything.
Sappoli will probably tell, okay, I'm seeing a foot or whatever, right?
That's the conversation that happens.
What?
Now, what do you want to do now?
Because they will force the robot out now.
Does the stealth check to get the lock?
Yeah.
Do I have advantage because they're distracted?
Yeah, sure.
Or because I'm invisible.
Well,
I'm gonna search.
You successfully unlock the door.
You can sneak in if you want to, okay?
You want to close the door or do you want to keep it open?
You close the door, you get inside, okay?
Shit, I'm gonna start walking over this way.
Because I'm gonna see the door opening closed, so I'm just gonna assume that it was her.
Sorry, red.
I don't know why.
Singing in the rain.
Okay, as you leave, the guard will escort you out.
I'll go a different way.
You go a different way this guard will probably escort you out.
Follow the mixer.
Oh, perfect.
Perfect.
Is this an alley back here?
Yeah.
Am I going into the open city there?
Am I going into the alleyway too?
Sorry.
What direction will this take me?
I don't know, like, in this alley.
There is a way.
He's probably gonna stop right here.
Because that's like beyond the boundary that he is allowed to go to.
You say he'll stop here?
Yeah, he'll stop here.
If you're going this way, that's where.
So then we got far enough away where Saplia can go inside with red, correct?
Yeah, I think you're far enough away.
No.
Saplia is all over.
Him, N, red, N.
What do you guys want to do now?
So he's the only one around.
No, the one is with Roma.
No one at this point is around here.
Can I take him out?
That's what I was just talking about.
Do you want to take them out?
Like, I was walking behind me.
I'm just gonna like, wheel around with it backhand.
Just making someone unconscious is just, you know, basically,
I'll actually do like that.
You have to do enough damage in that one head.
I can do it.
You don't have any damage.
No.
If I have a banished hit, it's possible.
Okay, try it.
Sure.
With advantage?
With advantage, because he will try to go back to where his post was.
Yes, he's not really looking at you.
If anytime I need to hit this attack, it needs to be nettle.
Come on.
Oh my God.
That is so bad.
And then the dice said you're here.
You wanted to solve the cool, but the dice said no.
You try to attack him and he sees you try to him.
And he's like, okay, what are you trying to pull?
He's going to throw his hand out.
He sees that both, there's no backup.
He'll try to call for the other guy.
He'll first his action would be disengage and run towards him.
He's on a run.
Yeah.
Now, I'm trying to attack this again.
You are, Roma, are still free to move.
What do you want Sapria to do?
Sapria to join in with you about this one.
Sapria is going to be, Sapria is going to fake a red.
Yeah.
So Sapria is inside the fucking bank with red and then he's going to take catch him and then haul him away.
But he also has the radio.
So he would have heard them radio this other dude to radio to this guy.
He's just trying to run and just call out to him.
He is engaged.
He might not have had to move anymore.
No, I want you to roll for initiative.
Say less.
I'm going to, since I'm all by myself with this dude, I'm going to turn around and crack him with the fucking frying pan.
Like, do that.
Do your attack with advantage.
Jesus, the power of the wheel.
Yeah.
Oh shit, I got to use this one.
Home on.
I can't meet a good two net one.
That's not a great way to start the session.
Reckless attack to the advantage.
Oh my god, what is happening?
You try to hit this guy and this guy will bring out his weapons as well.
You can also roll for initiative.
Everything's going to shit.
Why is my shit not like?
Okay.
I'm going to play in sucks.
Oh my god.
So I rolled that 20 now.
20.
Yes, initiative.
That's cool.
Yeah.
So, uh, Roma, it's your turn.
Let's go.
I'm going.
I'm swinging for the fences again.
This dude just popped out his gun.
It was like freeze.
I'm like, hell, not.
All right.
I'm going to play this again.
Great.
You can check that fucking.
Come on, for sure.
Let's fucking go.
To the damage.
Oh my god.
What the hell is.
Okay.
Uh, so you swing in a mess.
And then the marine guy fumbles around getting his gun.
Uh, while you swing again right at his face and he's knocked out.
Do you want to kill him?
Do you want to just knock him out?
No, no.
I'm going to knock him out and throw him in the bushes to my right.
All right.
So this guy is gone.
Now see, this was good.
I've happened the first time.
But it didn't.
So there we go.
And then while I'm doing it, because I know the radios have fucking, uh, like trackers,
I'm going to smash his radio and his little mushy, mushy thing.
All right.
I'm smashing both of them.
This guy is down then.
Uh, that's your turn.
Do you want to do something else?
Do you want to move to the other?
Oh, yeah.
I'm just moving.
I'm just going to stumble around pretend like I'm drunk and be like, sing in the rain.
All right.
Um, so he, uh, anything else you want to do?
Go to section anything?
No, I can't do anything else.
All right.
Let's go to, uh, he said the fucking dead marine.
Oh, I know.
It's the dead marine.
All right.
This guy is not that heavily unconscious.
Well, look around and see there.
He cannot see any of those submarines.
He'll look at you and be like, where's the other guy?
I saw him going the bank.
Uh, do, uh, deception.
Oh, fuck.
I did you think I was just a little.
I can't go far.
12.
You can, you can move 40, right?
I can't.
Uh, okay.
No, I'm not feeling.
He's, he's, he's through it and he's like, he was following you right at the go.
He will also try to reach out for his gun.
And, uh, he'll use his action to ask you to surrender.
He'll ask you to surrender.
What do you get going?
Get your hands up.
I, I'm on the ground.
So he's just going to forget all about that.
He's shit.
I'm going to pretend to throw my hands up.
Okay.
Stay right there.
Uh, he'll, he'll reach out and try to use his action for calling the thing.
Oh, this is where Sappley can respond.
Uh, do you want them to respond now?
Because he's just radio, he's just radioing to the other guy, right?
Doesn't take one time for him to radio.
Yeah, he will use his action to do the radio thing.
Then he will have called for backup.
And I'm saying this like that like made this earn or does it take a couple turns?
No, that's, that's this turn.
You can just call because that's his whole action.
He's going to spend a election just to call that.
That's all I was like, then, then, Hell yeah, I want Sappley to respond and be like.
What's going on, boss?
Or like, what's going on?
I can try to radio.
I'll say Sappley would have to disrupt the radio call and interrupt like it to getting out of this area.
And there was, uh, he'll, uh, she respond and come out.
What do you want Sappley to do?
Let me.
Should we add her in the initiative?
Yeah, I'm going to say that.
And then you look like she's going to take care of me since he had gone on Roma.
100% doesn't matter.
Oh, it's about teach turn.
You better fuck him up this time.
If he's still looking at Roma, he's looking at Roma, but he's also looking at you keeping an eye on you because you did try to head him.
Anything happens.
Fuck it up.
Quick rush in.
Oh my God.
I need the Lebanon higher.
That's all I need.
11 or higher?
Are you sure about that?
I don't know what I need.
I just know I need better than a one.
Can I argue for advantage?
No, no, you cannot.
Okay.
Dice cards be with me.
Oh my God.
Okay, that will hit him.
Yeah, let's do it.
Do the damage plus 10.
It's incorporated in the role, so.
Oh, okay.
15.
All right.
Well, uh, do you want to kill him?
Do you want to knock him out?
Okay, you swoop in, you just dash in and you just got punched him.
And he's down.
All right.
It's about the first.
It's like, why did you even call me here?
All right.
Well, he's down.
Do you want to throw him in the bushes as well?
Yeah, and smash his radio and tracker.
Is there a way to disengage his pistol?
Like, or is it like tethered to the suit?
No, it's tethered to the suit, but if you take of it,
the castle from the suit it forms work.
It's powered by the sword.
I got you.
Well, then fuck.
I'll just leave everything.
Uh, where do you want to put him away?
Right around the corner in these bushes where the other guy is.
Let's drop him there.
You guys can now head inside.
Well, I'm not where the hell is red.
I was just gonna reds inside trying to get to the, get to the chest.
So you guys want us to just stick out, stick it on outside?
Yeah, I was like, I look out.
Exactly.
Wait, hey, you didn't know it was around, right?
No one is around.
And I fly up to the roof to get a better view of everything.
So I can see if anything for many years.
The roof of the building will be higher than 15 feet.
So I don't know if you can.
Can you give me a dexterity?
Throw.
I'll check.
Axterity check and I'll say you can get up.
Here you go.
You get up on the roof because the casino isn't that far away.
You see that a bunch of Marines have started gathering there.
It seems like they have found the director unconscious.
And they have gathered there for some reason or someone has gathered them there.
I'll try to like, relay signal to the people down.
If we had some type of communication like a delimitial, let them know.
But if not, I'll like signal to rum in that director.
And sorry, you, one of you had the radio mushy and sapling had one of the radio mushy.
Yeah, I did. I gave it to Safflia.
Yeah, those people can communicate which one has the other radio mushy.
There was the two.
I have radio mushy.
Oh, that's right. I gave mine to red.
That's right.
Okay. Red has the radio mushy.
Safflia has the radio mushy.
I'd say Safflia can also send outside and relay this information from you to red.
Well, that's what I'm saying.
I'm just going to pretend to be the post guy.
Like he's going to be the fake guard.
So like he isn't going to go inside yet.
He's going to pretend to rest.
He's just going to pace around outside while, okay, let's just move to red then.
Okay. What are you doing?
None of the cameras are triggering you invisible.
So you can do this was supposed to be the place like on the right side where my cursor is.
This is the cabin for the director from the map that Bramble gave you.
I'm going to try the door.
Now you can open it.
You use the key.
You open the door.
Freaky?
Yeah.
Looking for a chest, right?
Yes.
Do I see one?
Can you do a perception for me?
Come on red.
You better get inside the cabin.
You see a bunch of...
Oh my god.
You see a bunch of lock boxes lying around.
Like, you know, the ones in bank and like the saves and all that.
You see a bunch of them on the wall.
But you don't see the small chest that...
What's it called?
Bramble was talking about.
Does he have a desk?
Like what's in the wall?
Find them all.
He has a desk.
He has just a wall with like a bunch of lockers.
Come on red.
Okay.
You want to check the desk?
Do a perception for me again?
What do you mean perception or investigation?
Oh, double being investigated.
I see you get it here.
I'm not going to do it here.
One of the wooden planks of the desk,
you see that this is probably hollow.
You try to open that part and you do see a chest as Bramble mentioned.
The same chest as Bramble mentioned.
What do you want to do?
You want to take the chest?
Because it's not that big.
You want to take the chest and just run.
Or do you want to look around more?
See if it's trapped.
I think that's some extra.
I'm doing it.
Come on red.
I would red be intelligent enough to think this is trapped.
Let's see.
He's probably just going to try to take it.
Puck it under one arm.
All right.
You take it.
Do you want to leave?
I'm going to leave.
That's my aim for.
Why not?
Be greedy.
We only have it now.
You here, Zaplia, say, "Oh, Baptiste wants you to look around more."
How far are they at this point?
Like, she says she's got the chest.
How far are the Marines from the casino?
Let's say it's been about...
Oh, Jesus Christ.
That's an add-to-ne again.
What do you want to do with that?
I was just kind of taking a piss with us in the after all 20.
Just generalism.
The sticking around here seemed like a wise decision to do.
Well, the Marines have been alerted.
It might not be such a good idea.
But it won't hurt if you look around for a bit.
The Marines are still at the casino.
They haven't moved from there at all.
Is there anything in the room that I'm leaving that I'm able to quickly grab that looks interesting?
There's again, like, a small diary in front of... on the desk of Delrod.
You like kind of put everything back so it doesn't look like it immediately looked like anything was disturbed.
Then I'll head out.
Push the plank in again.
You take the diary and you just head out.
Close the door.
Kind of crack open the door.
Be sure it's the Applius sending there.
Yeah, it's obviously still patrolling around this area.
Do I see anything from my vantage point?
You don't see red.
I don't see anything from the outside.
Why isn't it?
I'm letting me use ability.
What ability?
There we go.
What is that noise?
I re-roll it for you.
Why do I have two bad teeth here?
You said don't make it hard.
I just asked who fucking called and then you shot my ass.
No, it's on now.
Okay, Will pulls out like two hand knives and he spins them.
As he locks both of his hands, he will take his movement.
Go up here.
Let me make a textured jack for him.
Let's just hope he fails.
Oh my god.
Tiny.
Here we go.
Uh, and exterdy, exterdy, exterdy.
Oh, this is just a good, expect, expect, right?
He's going to succeed.
He's going to come up and he'll try to hit that beast.
Let's do this.
So he's just going to move right past me?
Yep.
Like, and right next to Baptiste.
Yeah, without Baptiste knowing.
He got all the way up to the top of the bank.
In one move, yes, his movement speed is 60.
Does that hit you, so any sex probably?
Let me do the damage.
All right, that's half the piercing damage, right?
Okay.
Uh, he takes the blade and he slices at you, but you kind of sort of face through it, but it still makes you.
Oh my god.
All right, it's, uh, red, do you want to do something here?
It's still sneak you can reveal your show.
I can just stay.
If you run away, this is probably the end.
What, what do you mean the end?
I mean, I can't, I can't say.
This is a scripted end.
I think I'm just going to hide the bushes for now.
I think Red's still trying to figure out what's going on.
I mean, you're invisible.
That's why they turned.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll just hide down here.
All right.
Is that you not even in the initiatives of the party?
It's time out.
I have a question.
We're going to rewind this whole thing because what wasn't,
well, what is, what's their name again?
Will and Circa.
Don't they weren't they weren't they sent by Black Hand?
They weren't sent back, but they haven't the thing to do with Black Hand.
Oh, say less than yeah, we fight.
Yeah.
Circa is going to just walk up alongside this like on the railing of the fountain and she's
going to come up to you and she's going to be like, you know, you can make this a lot more
easier.
Just tell us, tell us where, where the final one is.
I know she can, he can turn people invisible for somehow.
So he's probably doing that right now.
Just tell us, where he is, this will not be as painful as it's going to be now.
I'm going to be like, you shot me a little bit.
Yeah, because I'm going to feel like you just start.
I just ask who fucking call?
Who called you?
That's a simple question.
And then you shot my ass.
Now, you don't need to know who called us.
You just need to tell me where he is.
None your business.
If you ain't going to tell me who called, why am I going to tell you where they are?
You see how this goes?
You see she turns one of her arms into like a sharp blade and she's going to attack you
with it.
Does it have 15 heads?
So my question is, since I have a, since I'm raging and I have the, what is it?
Defense against blades?
Would that be with disadvantage?
No, so this attack is with advantage, right?
Which is your raging, but you have defense blades, so that's, that removes the advantage.
So it's just a normal role.
Just a 15 head.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
So it cancels it out, right?
Advantage, disadvantage is just normal role.
Why would she have advantage, though?
Because she walked up.
Oh, you're, you're raging.
You're not, you're not, you're not.
I'm, yeah.
You didn't do reckless last time, right?
No.
Oh, that was below.
Yeah.
Let me, let me roll for another one and then we'll take the lower one.
Normal.
That will stand on it.
That's the same little, oh yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We tried.
Let me damage.
She's going to swipe at you with the blade.
That will do 12 damage.
As she slices you, you start to bleed even more.
Now is it's your turn.
Yeah, at this point, I'm going fucking Hulk mode.
Where the fuck is my barrier?
Red, did you lock the doors or did you just close them before leaving?
I think I just closed them.
Okay.
Cool.
I didn't, I don't know what, did initiative for self, they're just giving one second.
Oh, God.
It doesn't matter.
No.
Anyway, all right.
You want to go the beast thing, right?
Let me do that.
Yeah.
Transformation, we go, Roma, go wild shape, go physical abilities, equipment, spells,
type, vision.
All right.
As you start to tear through your clothes when you transform into your Yeti form, what do you want to do now?
I'm going to attack the little thing.
Why isn't it not giving me the claws?
Also, why is it not taking my health away?
I just want to know, because I just want to do one.
If you regain your health.
Okay.
You regain all your health as you transform.
It's like wild shape, right?
So it's a different health pool.
I'm not, it's not let me do the, that's what you want to do.
Yeah.
It's too normal.
Because you don't want to reckless, right?
No.
Because I can, I can frost call ice, I can fall the bone.
So you left.
So would that be, since I rolled a 20, a critical hit?
Critical.
Well, a critical hit.
That was a 13 and 10 cold.
So she's going to take two less, she's resistance to bludgeoning.
So she's going to take half of the bludgeoning, but 10 cold will affect her.
All right.
That's your move or do you want to do something else?
I'm going to swipe at her twice, because it says I can do another attack as a bonus.
Do the wrong one.
That's it.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
So you swipe at her twice, doing immense damage.
What do you want to do?
So you just turn out into, I'm, I'm foaming at the mouth.
And I'm like, you still want to do this little one.
As you swipe at her, see, she tries to dodge out of the way, but both times,
both of your claw head for her right in the, like the torso area.
Do you swipe both times and you're just going to scratch her out?
All right.
Let's see who's next.
WebT is to turn.
You still have a question.
You haven't fallen down.
Both of you are on.
I just have a question.
If I, this is a buildup kind of question.
Could I get a damage if I, where's a lie him into the air and start fighting with him grapple?
So you'll, first you will have to grapple him.
Yeah, I know.
To use your fireman to just throw him down.
You want to throw him down or keep him grapple and then just.
You know what I'll just try.
I'll just try swinging.
Swinging never goes great for me.
You're going to, you're going to do the dumb gamble hit.
We could be.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Dice gods.
After this, it's up.
He's turned and we'll see what they do.
Let's go.
Come on.
I saw that 18 for a second.
You know what?
Yeah, that does not hit.
Where you bow?
That's cool.
I'm going to try two more times.
Oh my god.
That is not it.
And that does not hit.
That's he.
Bro, it's following.
As you swing on.
I'm not following these people.
It's overpowered.
These people are overpowered.
But that's another thing.
You, you try to hit him again and again and again.
He just switches and just moves out of the way.
Too quick.
You can't even tell how fast he's moving at this point.
And that is without his feet.
Of actually dodging.
By the way.
All right.
It's saplings turn.
Right.
If you want to do something here, you can still.
Just let me know whenever you want to make a move.
Okay.
Now, isn't saplings like the diplomatic person out of all of us?
Wouldn't he be like, let's calm down.
Let's calm down.
Like what is going on right now?
I'm going to say it's saplings turn.
She's going to go.
Why are you doing this?
We don't have to.
We don't have to fight.
Just tell us why you're doing this.
Do you want them to still try to attack or just.
That.
Well, if they don't.
Yeah, if they don't answer, she, she going to attack.
Okay.
So I had this point.
Let me do a persuasion role for South.
Yeah.
It might get louder in my enforce the drink.
That's fine.
Let me do a wisdom.
Why can't I do a wisdom saving?
How they go?
This is a wisdom check.
Where's the saving?
How they go.
Okay.
And I'm going to say that the answer is.
I'm going to say that the answer is.
If you can't.
Look.
We can't.
Is she bleeding by the way?
No, no, she's not bleeding.
That was you.
We told you we told you we can't make a move against the Marines.
But I didn't think they'd call us.
The first thing they do.
They'd never call us.
It's the fucking.
It's Delaroth.
He's the asshole who probably told them to call us instead of dealing it with themselves.
Anyway, we're here and this needs to stop.
Just tell us where he is and you don't need to die for this.
You don't.
At this point, I'd say it's up to you.
I would say no.
She's going to make a hundred coordinates.
Oh my god.
She's a Christ room.
Oh, Jesus, finally.
That will hit.
Let me do damage for the second row.
She's going to take.
Yeah, five of them damage.
There you go.
As Safiya says, it doesn't matter why you're with them.
If you're not with us, then I guess.
You fight.
She's going to pull out one of the hundred gone.
Let's see.
You can fire at her.
Safiya blocks it with one of her arms with the blade.
She just likes it that and the second punch hits her.
All right.
Next is whale.
He's still going to try to reason with you about peace.
At this point, you're pretty far away.
So you can't hear.
The Sramma, but he say, look, I don't.
I don't want to do this.
I like you guys.
It's not.
You have to understand it's not me.
We have to do this.
Okay, there's the lives at stake here.
At least.
Just let me get three free hits on me and we can talk.
Just pay back for that one.
That's like she did earlier.
I'm not sure if she's going to.
Okay, okay.
Can you do persuasion?
You can see my.
He might take that on just to avoid this fight.
He might do that.
Who my persuasion is not too good.
Can I do advantage to see his leaning and find?
I'm not sure.
Oh my god.
I'm.
All right.
This is the exact opposite spectrum of what Roma is pulling.
Anyone read that an actual 20 but okay.
So we'll just laugh it off and he says.
All right.
He'll hit you and he'll try to throw you out of the roof.
This time you'll have to.
That that is not hit you.
Does it?
Or is it?
No, it does not.
Okay, he's going to do another one then.
You call my line.
He's going to.
This is not his attack.
He's just going to throw you in.
All right.
So can you make a dexterity check to land safely down?
Dexterity check for acrobatic.
Acrobatic's dexterity.
It's the same thing.
Oh, maybe you have proficiency in acrobatic.
You're going to take.
Let me check.
I'm done for today.
I'm logging off.
I'm just.
Just real real quick.
Honestly, you take.
1d6, 2d6.
Lushing damage.
And you roll.
2d6.
Oh, that's a seven.
So that will be 12.
Did I get from your total?
I'll do that.
Okay, there you go.
Now you're lying on the ground.
You're not prone.
I'll just say that you're not prone.
You're still there.
You just took a bit of damage.
Vale is going to jump down.
Let me make a dexterity saving from him.
Well, he better fail this shit.
He has plus nine on deck.
Thank you.
Yeah, he's going to just jump down.
And he's going to circle you back here.
Right.
You want to do something?
How do we move on?
I'm staying in.
All right.
Have you been thinking of AC for me?
Have you been subtracting the AC?
Yes.
I was just checking.
It's circus turn.
She's going to look at Roma.
I don't.
She's going to look at the saffelia.
And she's going to go.
Why why did it have to be you guys?
I just.
I just wish there was another way.
But if you are not willing to budge,
it doesn't even matter.
You don't even know, Bramble like that.
Why why are you standing up for him?
Who the fuck?
Bramble.
What?
Oh, he's Bramble.
He's Bramble.
It's going to go.
Who the fuck is Bramble?
The person who you're doing the job for.
So this man told you guys to come steal from us.
After he told us to come do something for you.
He told us to stop you, get whatever you were after.
And that's it.
And this is why I am still asking you to just hand it over.
And whatever you stole, give it back and you'll live.
Because our orders is just to get that thing, not to kill you.
We've been proud.
This motherfucker wants you to steal from us.
Bramble didn't tell them they were sent here by Marines.
Oh, but that's what makes no sense.
Why?
Because I'm going to keep calling them will and I know it's not will.
We'll knocked out two Marines literally the day before.
This is not matter to us unless we are ordered to do it.
We don't do anything and they didn't see us.
So they don't know.
They don't know how to do it.
So you go knock out your own people, but then be working for them.
It's not like I like doing this.
No, fuck that.
It's all.
We're the ones that knock out the Marines.
No, no, no, no, no.
You know what knocked out two will knock out two of them.
Because you wanted to go through that alley.
Which makes no sense.
It will make a sense and I will read but.
Now I know you I know you lens.
Tell me what is Lynn want?
Lynn has nothing to do with this.
That's a lot because you said we could help with the plan.
Lynn has not been here in five years.
She's thinking what's happening here.
What's happening?
So you just you're working with the feds and I see how it is.
He goes away for five years.
You say fucking I work with the feds.
She's going to get really angry at you and she has this murderous look in her eyes.
And she will attack you now.
It's going to go.
That's it.
I'm putting it into this.
The teen does that head.
Just barely.
But she's still using her blade.
Yep.
Because I'm still technically raging.
So I'm still.
I have another one.
15 that still hits.
Yeah.
The lower rolls still hits.
I'll say you take five damage from that.
She's going to use her legendary action.
And she's going to roll again.
Doesn't very actually scream.
14.
She's going to.
Let me check again.
Yeah.
She rolls 14 both times.
19 does.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's do.
Camage for this.
Camage.
Thanks.
So she's going to pull out one of her blade arms.
She's going to slash at you.
She's going to turn the gun arm again into a blade arm and she's going to slash at you again.
Both times.
So you keep in track of the damage because it's not letting me subtract from 45.
Wait, it is not letting you subtract one.
Yeah.
It's not.
How much damage did she do?
Let me check.
13 and then it was like.
Oh, remember I have.
Yeah.
And 11 and 11 and that's 24 12.
12 is.
30.
Two.
Okay.
23 sorry.
All right.
Next is.
How much you turn?
Shit.
I'm doing it again.
I'm swiping twice with the frost clause.
So.
Have a question.
Is that with advantage?
Since I'm raging.
Yeah.
Did you not do it with advantage last time?
I thought you did.
No, because they're old 20s.
Okay.
15.
Do it again.
I'm assuming you want to do the bonus section.
Yep, yep.
That will hit her.
15 doesn't.
No, 15 doesn't.
Finally roll it once.
Eight plus the frost.
Why better again and.
It.
It slashes her from the side.
And she's still pretty mad.
And.
What does it want to do?
Do you want to do something else?
I don't think you can.
I can't.
I used all my answers.
Right.
Up to your turn.
You want to gamble again.
I'm going to do another one.
Do it again.
Damn!
That will...
That will more.
The 16 will not...
Oh.
The 7 will not hit.
Yeah.
But 19 will hit.
So do the damage for the 19 one.
19 one.
And then 2d4 because of the...
Grab the top one.
18.
And then you have 14.
But you...
14.
Plus 2d4.
You said it's 10 meters.
10 meters one way.
I mean he's still not doing the dc.
You could push him in the dc.
What was it dc?
Oh, a strength save.
He's still doing the dc.
There's been a 5 extra of 4th pinch.
Oh, okay.
5.
Let me do that.
Okay.
18, 14 and 5.
That's a 37 damage, okay.
Let me roll the strength saving check for him.
Okay.
Just say if he falls back.
He's going to use his legendary resistance here.
Okay.
He just not to get pushed back.
Because he's he's fucking, you know.
Proud, I guess.
I don't know.
He's going to stand there.
And you do three of your free hits, by the way.
All of these are coming as a hit.
Okay.
It's not like I'm going to let you do this three more times.
I know.
Yeah.
All right.
So you go around.
Well, it's standing his ground as you.
What do you want to do?
How do you want to?
I'm sorry.
What happened?
How do you want to do this?
Because he's he's he's just going to stand there.
He's not going to do anything.
Yeah, after he says yet, we agree.
And he's like, stand still.
I cracked my knuckles.
And then just like swinging.
Persona into the face.
First, you go right to his face.
You punch him in the face.
He locks his jaw.
But you still hit him.
You see blood kind of pouring out of his mouth.
You do another one.
Says at the face as well.
The same goes towards the back.
You want to punch in the gut now.
And that will also hit him.
The third strike you.
You probably don't know.
When he's like,
the third strike when he like.
Punched over from the gut throw.
I try to upper cut, but it just doesn't reach.
More doubt.
No, then you hit him in the forehead.
Let's do.
He's hitting damage.
I'm going to go.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
That's.
All right.
So you can see this.
She's going to go.
Don't fuck around well.
We have to.
We have to get moving.
What are you doing?
We'll go.
It's fine.
If.
If this will stop them.
I'm willing to take the chance.
It's a lot by this.
Just so you know.
It's saplings turn.
What do you want to do here?
What do you try to call him?
I'm trying to figure out what his character would do now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to figure that out as well.
I don't think she like the whole will taking the free punch.
I think that's what.
Like, like, would he.
They don't want to hold down.
They just know we're fighting.
Yeah, but she'll hear all of this.
Yeah, we heard the whole conversation.
Like.
Where's Lin?
I need to talk to Lin.
You guys are not making any sense.
Where is Lin?
And Serika is again going to say,
Lin has nothing to do with this.
What do you don't understand about this?
And Sapriya, I guess, will just talk an attack?
I don't know.
See that?
Like, I don't know if he would be like,
Lin took the punches.
Let's talk now.
Well, well, well, yeah, I don't know.
But I, but I don't know what, like,
if Sapri would do that.
Because like, we would be hearing this the entire time.
Maybe.
I don't think y'all would thought I'd say I would talk.
But that's what I'm saying.
I don't know if the captain would stop the fight and be like,
"Oh, I'm so bad."
And I don't know if the captain would stop the fight and be like,
"I get my six hits."
I'm like, "I don't know how saplings would play this."
'Cause like, he doesn't like us killing people.
So like,
"When is that anything about killing? We're just fighting."
No, no, no, no.
She's lost in the sauce, bro.
Yep.
She's gonna do thunder gondlets at Serk again.
She wouldn't want to see us get brutally killed either, so.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we're gonna start hitting.
You're gonna start hitting.
Oh, no.
Would invisibility fucking wear up?
Like, has it been an hour?
She's installed. It's not been an hour.
Oh.
God, damn.
She's installed. It's not been an hour.
Oh.
God, damn.
She's installed. It's not been an hour.
Oh.
God, damn.
She's not been an hour.
again he's gonna skip it's red red hello are you there we can't hear you're
ready yeah okay what do you want to do shoot so we got the debriefing for this
they don't know what we we're going after I think red is just going to get me
I'm not doing because I'm most invisible I am going to take the diary that I
got and not need to cause damage but I'm just gonna like throw it at
Saraga okay just trying to make it like a piece of offering to get everybody
to stop and just kind of go back into hiding and gawking in my bush okay throw
the book make what's your what's your spelling casting ability charisma right do
charisma check to see if that head okay you will be able to throw that to
Saraga the book lands on her on the back of her head and she looks around she
understand that it's probably you and she's gonna go red show your face this
does not have to go this way I will have you want oh go ahead I will start
blasting I don't care if I hit you or if you die I know what direction you
threw it from this is where sadly would you do you not say anything
I'll move up here I'm not gonna say anything she's gonna get myself wait yeah do gun arm sorry
with this advantage let me do this advantage she's just gonna stop coming after me
yeah and just start this respect that's what I'm saying like you think I'm doing a lot
okay do an opportunity attack you want to opportunity so what would that just be
just like it's a real attack so she's not really moving she's just turning around
and shooting that's all she's doing so I don't think they're going to be an
opportunity attack for that but like but that's why she on turn away like already
just later on pulling pulling out a fucking she's gonna change her arm and shoot
yeah she's just missing that she did I'll say you'll have an advantage on the next
head but that's about it that's all I can say she's gonna try to hit both times with
disadvantage one of the shots I'd say will still hit I mean she's invisible I
don't want to if she's shooting in this direction and she's probably not gonna
hit all right yeah both I'll say both both of them misses but that is her action
so wrong let's do it's your turn do with it advantage this is where this is where I'll
be like all you asked for was what you wanted what we stole we stole this book
thinking it was the ledger to whatever fuck you god damn it let's go she asked
what we stole that's not deception she did steal that yeah so but that's not
but you mean quite about it that's not the truth why isn't it let me it's not
even let me bring up my whole character menu yeah I know what some things
broken what let me do a deception for you don't suck don't suck for sure let me
do an insight she fails the insight I'd say sure why not she ain't I just rolled
the fucking eight okay yeah she has a system of plus two is not that good but she
can feel yeah she's not gonna feel all right she even let fail what do you want to
do now I'm shit I'm since I didn't see her lower guard I'm still going in
that's it that's it that way later yeah okay and then you want me to roll another
attack for the second one do you want to do your bonus action hell yeah
then do it oh my god I didn't fucking play any music Jesus Chris I'm so I just
hit it okay it doesn't show for the second and then it's whatever the plus
four for the cross being or whatever that already yeah eight and two right okay
so for those do you really want to die right here also she's gonna shout out Lynn to sorry not Lynn
well to get shit but it's not a game they have to do this we're just going to go yeah but if
this stuff the killing is fine is that your turn Roma that's all I can do
but like I already tried to deceive them somebody else can try to deceive them make them come
through your main bains that is back clean stop three hits please like that's with the rabbit of course I'm here yeah he can do it again to the end of the season oh no I was it's not just I just changed the name since last
point should be training oh no I did it I'm saying that should go let's go back again oh god oh god now that is not
hit as you land three flurry of blows into into whale he's just gonna stand there and look at you it's
gonna be like I guess that's it then let me let me count the strength what do you mean that doesn't count
row one the overstate fancy right what I didn't land it then it doesn't really what the fuck now no you land the head he's gonna
go back one before I don't know it so 40 image yeah max damage let's go roll max
all right I'm gonna explore this dude I'm gonna roll the damage for those attacks to see how much I
would have done I'm gonna torture myself it's happiest turn and she's gonna say okay
oh those are attacks your mean well this is what you wish for and you failed now every stop and
let's talk about this and then goes yeah that's what I want to talk about too he's gonna wrangle
everyone up here in between or oh you if you want to transform back it's fine yeah he's gonna
I don't have 49 and he's gonna just grab her and just keep her locked in in in his arm and she's
still going crazy I'm gonna get fuck all of you uh whale goes all right where's red
red show yourself it's it's time we had a deal and it's time for you to honor
you show yourself no well you got what you want it what you got what we stole that diary
steal the diary okay let me take a look at the fucking diary you looks at the diary uh let me do
we want to do cold aura no I'm trying to transform back I thought if I clicked on it let me let me
let me do that yeah it won't let me for some other reason there you go you I just want to know I'm
gonna take the gamble every time uh do do a deception again I'm gonna do it a wisdom saving for him
again if you do a deception whatever he rolls oh you know what you might I first get one of the night
I haven't got a good right things as will uh look said thing huh this might be it there's a lot
of stuff in here maybe this is what he wanted uh as he does that you see a bunch of marines
start to line up goddamn it you see two of these marines in a different kind of suit
while everyone else surrounds you I can't see those I only see one person in a different suit
yeah the dude still knocked out right the dude's talking like you yeah the phone is probably
blocking you it's fine there's there's another guy here let me actually just remove the fucking fountain wall
actually all right there you go uh you hear a voice from behind these two marines where you can't
really see and he goes the dogs have fashed good job dogs but that's not what we're looking
for you don't really see the guy who's talking uh valence rica go that wasn't the deal that
he's no that's what I thought she stole be like that's what we thought she stole like or not be like
that's what we stole that's what we stole yeah but the marines didn't lie but I don't know
what she stole I just thought that's probably still on site whatever you're looking for
what the hell you want it's too late I can't wait for what do you do you not see around us
this is it this is your end I told you to give up I told you if you just handed that thing over
it would be over and we could move on but this is what you wanted what we stole
so you were stolen by fighting where is red I want to hear this from him where is he
calling him here that was the deal that what now the deal was give you what we stole that is what we
what we stole I don't know if red took anything else that is what I told you that was the deal
the deal was the deal the deal was give you what we stole a fucking idiot yes because you don't
know what you even we're looking for okay oh my god okay uh he's gonna he's gonna just
say I guess I guess you guys just won't listen I gave you I guess you won't listen I gave you a chance
but this is it Sarika I won't interfere go ahead we'll just steps back uh toward the fountain and
Sarika who's turn was it sapling is turned okay what do you want sapling to do here because the
the negotiate since have broken down uh so we are back in college idiot
can we re-reward this you guys uh I'm already two guys personally I say kill them
okay you fake kill who kill kill both of them sir have not yeah yeah that's my vote okay so
I guess I'm the only one I can't worry as low as many more so I'm kind of
well they go uh that's not gonna hit Sarika and let me see another one
as far as you can tell village is sitting back and letting Sarika handle this he's not gonna interfere
that what are they in our east morning waiting to go so who's this random dude that just walked up
he could yell at us but we can't see him no he's far back in the shadows you can't see him
I read your turn what you want to do
right okay run out from visibility I'm going to
can't you any big spells anymore
time to do the damage I'll see that hits her over that oh no I'm looking at the
tag within a manage oh okay okay you're just looking that's fine
I'll fucking lie as well thank you 16 yep there's a damage there's a advantage come on
he still has her gun pestle in her hand right no that the invisibility has lifted
and one point of damage bullshit oh well you know there you go this that's uh
no it doesn't even is that electric yeah she has lightning resistance that doesn't hit her
oh the fucker how does she have lightning resistance she she
she takes the damage just on unity because dams that's how I'm moving on um yeah all right let's
sit let's see hold on I mean bonus action I'm gonna give
my shit uh party conspiracy to Roma
night roll
shit and then oh my all right the day is not your side today I mean your guys are not
like you're very wise decisions as well uh we'll see as soon as you got off your
invisibility he's gonna dash and he's gonna grab you let me do a grapple for him
can you do a uh strength saving check red oh my god Jesus Christ where
all right uh you do it but I don't I don't think you're too old yeah okay he tries to grab you uh but you
dodge away uh let's go to Sarah Kerr she's gonna look at you and she's gonna go
you have to choose now I mean I guess at at this point it doesn't even matter the Marines are not
gonna let you go even if we wanted to let you go so hand it over so you don't have to die
you know let's say oh boss fight
we're just kind of squawks it says too late all right well she's gonna you
once in the lifetime attack I guess let's see uh did
uh sure go ahead
but why is he is she not oh I see is yes see I didn't
oh my god I was testing something out and then it's
god damn it uh for our small book you
there you go
brother roll better
okay uh she's gonna do her ability and she's gonna go hit all
off you in this cone now go maybe you feel more inclined to behave
if everyone in your crew is dead
you're gonna target these three I want you all to make a DC 16 Dexter in the saving draw
uh let me do that for saplia
next save is the she has no advantage when dex saves them it normal
the saplia fails to my character right here
that these fails Roma
Roma can you not do the dex save
I can't hear him I'll just save it for
uh Roma fails as well oh god just don't die just don't die try not to die from this
because it will they will out of fucking damage 19 19 to all three
who
I big ha why
that's a that's a weapon attack there's a there's logia oh yeah you do take half that
me see 19 19 is no that's fine I did that happen you calculated it yeah okay okay that's why
all of you took half right no okay you took if Roma was the way he took half
no he probably was out of the boat right you transformed out and he took the damage
okay she's gonna what she does is she just overloads all her her parts of the body she's like
there's like a cannon jutting out from her torso there's the both of their her hands combined
into one cannon there's another cannon out of her right side of the torso and she's gonna blow
four or five times from the cannon and it's gonna just blast you guys away all right so
as she does that you see all of your she made slaughter yeah yeah wouldn't she hit that guard standing
behind us she's she'll let her go if you want to do that then sure she's gonna she's gonna kill
the guard as well she's gonna just straight up kill him that fingers the Marines and they start fighting
here I don't know it's gonna happen but sure the Marines look at this and they just grab this guy
and take him away that's it that's all they do wow that man that guy from the shadows is like
well this wasn't the deal get them now or I'll have to step in uh oh that's
Sarah Kastern but she's gonna look at red one more time and she's gonna go this is this is just the
beginning do you want to keep going with this well I'm just gonna take that so I would know uh
romance your turn it's just kind of saying don't stand between a part it's treasure so I'm
I can only go Hulk mode once right uh what you can't transform back no that's what I thought
so fuck I just got fucking blasted so I don't know what the fuck to do
fuck we get by the way I the next turn you have to do something all of you are gonna die
he would say his leg fucking dead fuck it let's we swinging for the fences again I guess
okay at this point exhausted and just out of them you still do reckless attack do uh do the head
like where the fuck
so since she looked away would it be with advantage no no okay still don't need it that that
hit her do the damage okay okay you hit her with the pan she just looks at you with
just disappointment and she's like sure why not they see the blood splattering out of her
mouth as you hit her uh what's uh it's your turn Baptist what are you gonna do I can do some we're
all at this point it does seem like we're all going to die correct I mean if you three die and red
does not give over the thing then yeah you're going to die my orders from black and worse and make
sure sappy of this yes uh this can be really stupid okay okay that's a time short of stupid
thing that's fine no this is like very very stupid okay I don't know how stupid this can get but
sure it's not stupid it's stupid on one end but on the other end it makes sense uh-huh
from my line it's like oh I did not need to do it but do I see like a door is closed so it's an
action to open the door just so you know okay no no no yeah uh how far is it to the top of the um
good thing uh I'd say if you do succeed in the acrobatics section you can get to the top
but where is probably going to put a stop to this immediately as soon as you try to move
that's the thing I mean that's what I would like to know I know I know I know
I really want to do whatever the fuck you want that's the beauty of this
take this I'm taking off my disguise fully
uh let me do that for you all right there go oh oh my god are you actually doing this
there was insanely stupid actually no mine and then I will fly
the the man's voice is coming from below right yeah below 20 20 feet you can only
let me have your movement if it's a dash I can do 40 40 yeah
that one guard can't take me out question mark you don't know the whole thing is around it you don't
know that's what I'm saying this guard just got pulled away because he so when they pulled him
away did they pull him pulling away or is he just like still pulling down here he just pulled
him away and just maybe like put him near the bushes I'm going to fly just so just so you know
wheel has a movement speed of 60 I know okay it's you still want to do that right like if you
with that right flash showed up in the air but didn't see it because there's gonna
fucking shoot me we're screwed no matter what yeah like go ahead go ahead make it
this thing and whatever it's fine it's not fine it is not fine
I want to cry I really do
wait if I fly like diagonally in the air 10 really that's 40 even if I go that way I just like
I'm still I'm elevating it well off right move it so if you're elevating I'll drop the
distance down so if you're elevating to 30 10 feet then you can only move 30
10 yeah no preparing in the room
okay oh wow
yeah oh I collided with the wall
private rooms and there's a lot of people here is there a tour
it's very fucking right now like I don't know what do you do it's your turn I'm just trying to move my
character where where do you want to go here to be this way let me know you there
let's see let's see your action yes
it's happy it's turn she's at not so much she's not good doing well she now this and this
point I guess
there is going to uh snappier goes no one maybe she would just want all of you to fucking die let me do
what is going to save him check for her and tell him sorry oh okay okay she's gonna go Roma just
just hide it over I think it's not worth it I don't it's worth I know the idea this is what
now I just sacrifice myself oh the sacrifice yourself how are you running away
but they see what I am I know you know
oh they're gonna capture it regardless
if you give up or not it doesn't matter but they do want you alive
don't never take me alive
now we're gonna take me alive that's all you need to do me uh all right so I
pop in the ear that's that's the captain's orders what are you doing close up please orders
the captain's orders are just just give it off okay whatever it is just hand it over
bro something's gonna be pissed whatever I'm doing I'm not doing it well
I'm just saying they never even want to check inside the building it could still be in the building
yeah but they know you have it how it was that's what you were here for
I'm on the brook and I don't see anybody coming they
but it embodied us they also have not it been in our favor all day
I ain't complaining but what I'm saying is they don't know if we actually grabbed it nobody
went in the building and actually searched they don't need to know though they called them
right and they of course knew that what you were after was probably not some fucking book
it could have been a ledger it's a it's a paid book I mean you didn't even look once in the book that
that's fine um
all right so what are you gonna do red
can't do any kind of damage to make a difference um
Brenney is gonna suck too
blame
I'm just gonna take the box under my arm and just kind of drop it on the ground
cross my arms all powder
oh good okay as soon as you do that you see
Lynn coming out of the bank
and you see a bunch of smoke coming out of the bank as well
as he walks out he's gonna say
well
you don't need to do that red
I think all of this is going to stop now and uh
Sarika and we'll look at Len and they go what the hell are you doing what why would you do that
uh he goes because you did not told me that you were marine dogs now
uh Lynn looks pretty mad at both of them and both of them kind of look away not like trying to
get like eye to eye to his and uh he goes well it's all about to stop because you don't need to do
what you're doing and I know what you're doing yet so let's put an end to this you see the guy
that was in the shadows now walk up and he goes
blindness what is this about
what did you do uh he goes I burned it I burned all of it uh so he goes
uh he burned what uh as Lynn says that you see
Delrot run to run from the like the right side of the where you guys came from essentially
he runs toward here he sees all the commotion he hears Lynn talking about burning it all and he says
you burned the you burned the deed are you fucking crazy uh uh he's gonna shout at this guy and
he's gonna say "Voro you have to put a stop to this uh Virgo's uh do I need to put a stop to this
what is he even talking about uh Lynn goes oh I guess he didn't you didn't even know world
he had the deeds for everyone's debts on this island which he gave to every merchant
everyone who has a place to live here and he now holds that to
as uh what's it called fucking blanking out black yeah he's he's doing that to blackmail
well them he makes them pay the debts and the how he does it is by using
veil and seroton I knew I knew something was off as soon as I came on this island I knew
something was off with both of them they would do some things that I I know that they wouldn't
normally do like this why are you listening to them why did you get that call why why did you do
this and then I figured it out I talked to some of the merchants and they told me that you've been
out here collecting debts now why would you do that why would you need to do that he looks at
seroton well and they they don't say anything I know why you did it because delrot that bastard
told you he held that against you that's why the the armada was trash because you were the
bounty workers in this place in the debt collectors the debt collectors for everyone on the sign
so I burned all of it I took the chance I saw a death uh read unlock all the doors I took the
chance in the commotion to sneak into the bank and burn it off the borough goes doesn't matter now
that you've done it I think you and six falls are going to pay don't you think Lynn uh he goes
curious I would like to know if the Commodore knows about
borough kind of looks scared for a bit and he goes might be right but it doesn't matter if you are all
dead then it won't matter let's end it here and continue from tomorrow at this point I don't know
what to do you can fly away brother why did you why did you do that I guess
took me I know I know it this will not
well it went off the rails pretty quick I should have I should have delayed this for tomorrow because
I don't think I did well with a saptius character
but I guess Lynn is on your side now kind of so maybe you can survive this still I don't know
about Serkin well though I still don't know if they'll take your side now because the the reason
that they were fighting is gone I can't fight anymore I mean lose here he's gonna he's gonna get
you up unless he can bring back my key I can't fight oh you can't fight you don't have key point
I mean you can't still fight you just don't you know if you do gamble there's there's a reason it's
called gambling think these big fights you need to gamble because I want to be doing damage otherwise
the the damage I do through gambling that would take a full turn
well just to get you to see what happens what happens when the good saptius about the both did that
took place in it let's see oh my god we're gonna do three unarmed shank damages and compare it to one
gamble damage three and then this one I statistically I think it you would have done better
if you were to do if you were to do yeah three unarmed strikes what three equal to one so
and if I live three though yeah but you don't have high chances to hit
guy dammit this this was so far off the rails that I'm tired word but okay that's fine
night have a good one all right
my characters in my a you're smithing he's gone he's left us
I didn't leave you I tried to pull their attention away and then something else happened
yeah you didn't need to do that but I couldn't tell you that that that was going to happen right
I was waiting for this situation to happen maybe like a lot of people get involved and then
Lynn will try to sneak away I was doing some private roles as well
uh so he successfully snuck in burned the fucking deeds or whatever and now we're here
so everyone here has to die well either that or they convinced word to back off
no they have to die because they know who I am now yeah well that was what was not something I was
thinking of and now that this guy has seen this this guy right here he's not gonna he's
not gonna let you go how big of a bag okay so my question yeah they they only wanted the thing that
fucking red dropped so they would just fucking arrest us they didn't so okay here's the confusion
like boss did not call the six faults Delrod did the the fucking director
because because they have anything on them the director so how did the Marines come to the casino
that's what they were informed by Delrod as a backup to go and capture the whoever broke in the wall
the Marines don't know what you stole Delrod knows what you stole probably but again this is what
I'm saying though like the how did they know to come to the bank because we didn't set off any alarm
right there on the casino right yes but they're still dealing with the fucking knocked out dude he is
the knocked out dude this one over here he's not that dude he's right here I mean it's been like a
couple of hours right since no it's only been an hour because she even if it's a bill in the
top wait no no she attacked that's why her invisibility but that's what I'm saying so it's been under an hour
I guess the invisibility does not really go off unless I let you know cross it out the timing does
not matter here I'll say it's two hours where you're fumbling around fighting these guys I think
that's more than enough time for them to well the crowd the marine crowd was already gathered there
it doesn't matter if he was up or not he called them as soon as you left the thing well it's
probably he's gonna make it here like in like two seconds it doesn't matter to him but what I'm
saying is now that they got there because the whole thing was give us what you stole and we'll let
you go he put it down red put it down but it's not it's not in either of their hands
but that's our thing yeah our thing technically right now red dropped it
Lynn interfered so that's all their bullshit as as the the two with us or like we were fighting
this whole time they got what they wanted so they would just be like all right well this is what
we came for again it's not like they wanted to get it they were just doing it because of delrah
but that but that's what I'm saying so now that they have it they would slide with us they have
a no reason to fight for delrah they have every reason to fight for you that's what I'm saying so
they would join us yes and they don't need the chest anymore oh so then red would just pick
that bitch back up yeah and red is almost no damage I don't know if they have any healing stuff
on them let me check well there's the song or where that's so as I was flying out delrah was
coming back in right yes so what wouldn't Baptiste just grab his ass and be like no because that
would have ruined the whole role play thing I would have probably screwed back because would I
have seen any more guards coming this way I would have seen a lot more yeah yeah there's going to
be guards let me show you if you're I didn't remove the invisibility that's fine you've seen there's
going to be more guards here so if he saw somebody coming with the whole bunch of guards wouldn't
you've started to fly back I mean you he had to red drop the line of like 10 he's 10 feet above it
doesn't matter to him if I would have heard Lynn talking and then yeah the director also talking I
probably would have turned back yet but then I'd also tell you we have to kill everyone I know in my
head we have to kill everyone because your your whole thing was you had to keep sapling alive
sapling is yeah obviously bleeding out currently so your whole thing would be like all right we got
to get out of here but no but me flying away was like the the world government wants my people
yes they want you they were especially realistically they should have chased after me instead of
working about that box but they didn't which is what I thought they would do didn't because like
it's not their turn right you you made the move the Lynn came out and that said we don't know what
they'll do they didn't have any reactions on me doing that well they saw you were definitely saw
you do that but he didn't really focus on you at this point he just saw the wings and he saw
you fly away the conversation he had with Lynn of course he still has you in mind he maybe
tells some people to follow you but he won't go there personally not yet
again you're not that far away like 30 feet is not that far away he can he can maybe
like send some people to stop you like shoot at you shoot you down but that's it he can do anything
he can really do much here in this case and do we remember where sapling a left is armor
like it's good armor at the base of six folds armada
the sass for that armor is not that different she just switched it off essentially so it doesn't matter
and Marines would not know who's inside that armor
because for Marines the the armor itself is the pirate not not the person they don't know who's inside
the armor right that's what i'm saying so as of right now they think that this random ass marine
because they just walked up yeah there's probably someone in the armor that was taken they probably
would have figured that out from that place and now this place which is not guarded anymore
there's just one Marine and somehow they're fighting for you guys so they would have figured it out
but like this i'm gonna be honest this is the only part that i'm not getting because
app both sapling and red had radios with their stage like with theirs why wouldn't they be getting
caused that they wouldn't there's again radio you have to switch to a frequency they don't know the
frequency right it would it would have been the the one that they we picked it up no you picked
your three we've got frequency for you guys to talk in wind yeah i don't remember that i remember last
time this is what you said of okay i like that i'm just saying we all we're all fucked like
because because i don't get it like the whole the whole reason they all came to us was for the
the the the box we dropped the box so they essentially should have just scooped us up and arrested us
but now you're saying they don't give a fuck about the box they're just gonna kill us now
who like that's what the Marines
you whoever the shadowy figure was he wanted the box but now you're saying the manner whatever you
stole for him it just seemed like the book was probably not the thing that you stole
right i mean even sapling and sorry sir can veil knows that that's not the thing you stole right
i do like to do some deceptions and we did and and he his deception passed so they should have thought
we stole the the ledger and you said this dude's like that's not what they stole and i was like how
does he know what we're looking for yeah they can't yeah they can't he would know that he didn't
stole steal the fucking ledger he knows what the ledger is but we but we did steal the book that was
that was the one thing and it's not what he's looking for probably Delarot probably told him what
they are after after something exactly they're after the chest that you're so they know what they're
after so when red dropped it they would have all been like let's go get this chest no they would not
have been like that because they sent sir can veil to take care of it they they and they are still
hanging back because they're just looking at this but but that's the part that i'm not understanding
because you said they know what they're looking for you said you just so like if red drops the
chest that's what they're looking for they know that's what they're looking for they can't go out of
order right so they dropped the chest baptismos lind comes out and that's where we are they can still
move for the yeah okay that's what that's what i'm trying to figure out like are they still trying
to go for this chest they they will still try to go for the chest but for now you don't know if
valence Eric of the fight for you or not that's probably up to win to convince them
are you guys to convince them
that that's i feel you yeah i'm getting i'm getting a little too far ahead that's why
yes because it's literally lind's turn right now yeah so lin is just
has done this whole fucking thing you're my mom to release the i don't know the black male whatever they
have on real and cerica i got you so potentially they could fight for us if we wanted them to but like
there's no way we're going to know there is no i did not think that you would bring cerica down to
have her help and i did not think that i mean whale is good but he's also close to have help
so if even if lin will and cerica fought this guy i don't think there's there's
all the bugs on one side and these two guard these two marines are like
semen first class so they're like two grids above the normal marines question yeah what are the
limitations to lind's phasing lind's phasing he has one awakening move but he cannot do that
that all like even in like month he can mostly do it once
and one of his he is of course it just heals people
uh but yeah he can face through attacks and just disregard the damage that's no issues
unless it's hockey but but can he phase like other people while he's touching them yes
but he needs to be five feet or closer but i'm saying if what because we're all lined up right here
except for baptize like he's put like but potentially he could phase us out of this battle
correct where in the ground you can't do that for long though right he's like
if someone shoots at you he touches you the the shot will go through you but that's the fact
that's that's it 12 seconds and it drops
well that's that's quick enough because he awakening is maybe a more long lasting but he won't use it
but i'm saying if he just like because the whole thing is sapling it has to live
i'm just trying to keep that in my head because she's the captain like he just grabs fucking sapling
and just fucking starts running away lind at most he's like uh he's like a kind of mastermind kind of
guy he will know what to do in this case i don't want to say what he's gonna do but
i mean first of all there's going to be a fight and if those sounds i didn't know if i can add some
i didn't know if like he had some ninja smoke type shit like
no pop that shit on the ground he's mostly gonna do it with words
is anything but nothing other than that
well it's still his fucking turn isn't it uh i mean he hasn't done anything yet so it's probably his
turn still he can still try to talk to world
now what i'm saying is he would talk to the the siblings
the siblings would probably tell them to just back off now at this point sacrifice yourself
yeah i don't think he's gonna do that he doesn't care that much about you guys okay
those two people he's known for fucking years
you he's just met like a month ago and just just traveled the seas like we're hired to get
information from like we've grown a bond like i fed him i don't think you did you have maybe on
the boat but not not the not the fishman means that that will bond you for life you will take that
you wasn't there he wasn't he wasn't there for that so i worry yeah yeah yeah because he went back to
the place he took in that then he'd be like locked in brother i can't let you tell people that
he's a person but that's what i'm saying he wasn't there so like he's still one of the homies like
look he probably still saved your ass from a tpk most likely
obviously i mean the if you surrendered the thing then
then they wouldn't probably kill you but now the about pieces you know he did his thing
but but that's what i'm saying like they might they might go after him like since they saw that
like they will have to go after him
because they don't want us so i guess red time to pick a bit back up you know
i have no idea because i don't know what the hellbath he says like yeah you don't know what he is
i you probably wouldn't know what i mean most people would not know who or what he is at this point
that's what i'm saying so i'm gonna be like what the fuck the fuck he's left you what the fuck
and that's what it looks like as he's flying away where the fuck you going you just don't leave us you bit
exactly with the very side point
oh my casino bear he's too oh no he just took the murder you just call my buddy mother
fucker it was my money i wanted you wouldn't need your money fair and square yeah i threw in 25
oh please all right well it's it's up to you guys to explain all of this shit to his left
well maybe maybe you figure something out in in the downtime that what what are you going to do
get out of the situation that's what i'm saying like fuck we're kind of fuck here it's close to midnight so
yep have a good one no no i'm saying it's close to midnight in game time
oh oh is it a full moon going for right it's been you we go make out we go make out oh shit yeah
i mean so oh shit and sapling you and red it will probably gain all their health back
oh hell no we gonna make out yeah just stop it if you're a long rest you're not coming back
you want to just wait you ain't gonna long rest eight hours and then you'll come back
that's that's insane right with backup i mean they're they're gonna go after you even if it's not like
the the the main guy he's probably gonna send the first first class team in after year
yeah you will because they can just fight the regular at maybe in here
so i have a question that's enough i can't well my feral state be just like my Hulk state where
like i could do two swipes of the claws but just not with the snow damage let me let me do let me
check the so long for is it like that's what i was just gonna ask let me check so long okay starting
your transformation lasts for one minute or until you end it as a bonus action during your during
your during it your speed increases by 10 feet you have advantage on strength checks once and once
once on each of your turns you can drill extra electric damage to one target when you deal
damage to it with an attack or or spell that extra electric damage equals to your level so you level
three so whatever you do that will do another extra three damage but you won't get any of your
snow abilities because this will be yeah in voluntary transformation you won't trigger it yes it
was just happened so it's like it's like we're us normally because i'd be swinging the fine pan for
yes you and then i would just you you just you were just wild out turn like your white you will
maybe grow a bit bigger and you you will still use your what's it called the fucking weapon
whatever you have on you seem for same for red i'll i'll make you do a wisdom check just so i
can check if you are in control or not if you're in control you will know who to fight
but if you're not then oh hell oh hell there's only how many people are around you one two three four five
five yeah you will choose one out of five whoever you want to attack most likely the ones behind
or in front of you that's about it but you only need to do a successful wisdom 10 check
once to get full control so let's hope you roll better this time i'm rolled fantastic what you mean
you rolled fine you are the only one who was doing damage you're fucking very huh that's what she said
like with better rolled to a damage
yeah well you know i can't wait hopefully like this it can go one or two ways like everybody just says
fuck it and start chasing after Baptiste and or everybody stays here and fucking
we got to fight everybody and then we all die like it's one or two yeah i can't wait to see
i can't wait to see i can't wait to see i can't see if Baptiste would be still looking at everything
that's happening here he would see linda he would hear what linda saying so it's up to him to
he if he still wants to go over there he run off he can do that i'll say the marines will have
disadvantage unlike shooting him but that's about it shooting him down because no one can well
not no one but some people can get to him but not the normal marines or the first class recruits
that's how i'm saying him camouflage camouflage camouflage you're the way
the sky so like your wings are camouflage me as a whole oh my wings are black
i'm black that's why i'm wearing white dress i feel like i'm still wearing some black
yeah i think below the waist i think for sure because my thighs are black i just took off enough to
like i said you have this disadvantage but they can still see you i'm just saying
this is this is gonna be fun i want to see how this should place out
yeah let's hope it plays out better than than this time but
see everything's on the rolls man i don't know i don't know what to do here
i can't just leak everything in automatic success two of it i gave you like six free head brother
i don't know what you want for me no i know
uh just the timing was a bit off i thought you'd be in the uh you all would be in the
fucking um bank for longer so i could just do the main transformation while you were fighting
these guys but you just came out way too quickly for that to happen that's what the brown
more we could have found those talking it's you could have if you look around and if
red let's say investigated a bit more maybe open the chest check what inside it because you still
don't know what's inside it the chest that bramble sent you before if you did that you looked around
in the lockers there was in the room with uh in the room for the director you would have
find out found out what the fuck is happening but again it says something again i have everything
there but you know you don't know so of course you won't love i'm blaming and i'm the same there's
like ways it could have gotten it but which and that trust me
i honestly did not hear any of you
no i they actively agree with you like at no point did we ever open the chest at no point did
like all she all she did was look at the room once and then looked at the desk
yeah got the chest got out took the book again didn't even read the book
she threw the book away uh i mean you know it's fine it's not like you can read my mind like what's
happening but yeah exactly
but it will survive played out the way it has played out it's here now there's just and i need to
do some cleanup because either they have to be like hit with the you know men in black fucking
what's the memory raising thing what's called what do we know either they have to be hit with that
or they will not stop until they find fucking bad things but that's what i'll say it but like
if Baptiste is fast enough he could get away and fucking quickly switch back to the masquerade chase
sequence with Baptiste and while you guys are fighting these guys that that can answer whatever you
guys decide i can't really switch back to masquerade because they saw me transform from that disguise
so i have to do different yeah you'd have to do something else but like
but what i'm saying though is it all comes down for what the guard are doing try to
stealth down and maybe just disappear for a bit and you can look over to these guys
didn't you have like some healing kits let me talk or you do you can use the healing kits to get
your health back up and just join that's what i'm saying you have standard marine kits you have three
of them it all comes down to what the guards are going to do like if they know thereafter that species
of whatever fucking species that is like if they if all of them just say fuck it and run after them
because of like if it's that popular he would have a bounty of like something outrageous where they
wouldn't even give a fuck about this situation yeah and then like we could only be fighting this big
dude down here that morrow dude because like he's the only one who really knows what he was supposed
to get like yeah again i feel like there's like kind of a conflict for warro in this case because
even though that's what i'm saying hollvard is like a big deal he does not matter the least to
fucking warro he does not give a shit that's a captain of the marines and that's some guy
for working for the world government bank and he clearly did not know about the shit he was doing
behind his back so he may just say fuck you i don't care about you that's what i'm saying it all
comes down to what they're gonna do yeah i mean i just have to roll for it but we'll see
yep because that's what i want to find out like if they're gonna go after baptis because he's
the he's the only dollar prize you have to kind of fight him at this point if baptis didn't go full
what's it called but that's what i'm saying like it may be three minks
Lynn fucking well in sterko yeah going after one dude yeah that's what that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying i just want to see how it plays out like i don't know if like some of the
guards would stick with warro or like because you just had a million dollar prize just five pass
he's the one and of the one clearly just so you guys know cerica could probably beat this guy
one on one if she was at full head and she didn't use the attack that she used on you guys
but i don't think she can now uh also they were kind of holding back the veil was probably holding
back the most he didn't attack he's holding back more than one he attacked you twice that's it
that's what i'm saying like i really want to see how this plays out because you could take this like
forward different ways yeah but like i want to see how it plays out
yeah all good things that's what i'm saying all good like we we fucked we put you in a
rock in a hard place right now because that comes down to you and how you're gonna fucking play
i mean i have a week to decide that's why i stopped here brother i don't know what to do here
that's what i'm saying like you you have the tough decision like you're gonna be over there making
rolls like how's this gonna play out like yeah i have to roll for warro i have to roll for fucking
this guy delrot i have to roll for Lynn i have to roll for cerica and whale but but it's up to you
what you're gonna do that's up to you but it's not because it's whoever's turn it is it's whoever
makes an extra whale if he let's say if Lynn convinced whale lexus whales turn
though there if he decides to help you he could probably take out like three of these fuckers
on the right side but then that's what i'm saying we might not even have to do that if the guards
just dip like that's what i'm like it may it may be like we may not have to do anything except fight
moral like maybe maybe we could just engage with the world and let you guys run away but it's up
with work which is how not not gonna work hard for whales but what i'm saying though is it might
all come down to Lynn because it's still Lynn talking to him like that's it's it's gonna come out
it's gonna be crazy i can't wait it's gonna be crazy especially if you're you're doing rolls
the entire time like is is Lynn's shit gonna be successful yeah no shit now we're still fighting
fucking fight usually and the way that it played out today i don't think it's gonna work out
it might though it might though brother's the start is just too back to back critical
fails damn the first oh i know i saw that i was like what's wrong like what the fuck
false followed up by a second one i was like yeah that's crazy that's insane
but like well the yeah you but like whale like he didn't want to fight to begin with
i can't wait i can't wait to see what's gonna happen in front and took six fucking heads right
to his face that's what i'm saying like you didn't want to fight you like
that's like it's gonna get it's gonna get good yeah i can't wait good let's see uh i hope the
party two does better today because they're gonna fight someone uh who might not be easy to beat but let's
see it's gonna be fun if both of you a guy that fucked on the same day
but have a have a good night and you guys next week i have a piece but
yo what you turn on